hey guys what's up this is andrew from
dreamsenses.com so as you can see i am
still
in my quarantine hotel but i feel better
today my voice i hope
sounds better too so today i want to
make an update on tesla
fubu tv and blackberry for those who
want to get some insight
about gme and anc i posted this morning
some daily updates and i'm going to do
this every day about
yesterday's price action and i gave you
there my different scenario so just go
in the description click on the link in
the description of this video
to access my discord channel so today
let's analyze tesla first let's get into
[Music]
it
so i haven't made an update on tesla for
quite some time
uh but it's very very interesting what
is happening
here guys so let me sum up a bit the
situation all right so this is a tesla's
chart on the daily timeframe i take a
step back here
uh because i want to analyze this whole
move up so for those who have watched my
previous video on tesla you
have already seen that this has not
changed for quite some time guys
i remember the beginning of the year i
was telling you guys we completed the
third so basically
there's five waves here so once again
for those who are new to my channel
moves up developing five waves guys this
is elliott wave theory
and moves down develop in three waves
abc
for those who want to know more about
that same thing click on the link in
description of this video
and you're gonna have access to a free
training where i explain everything
about edit wave theory
that is very very precious guys when you
analyze
some stocks like tesla that grew a lot
you know eliot wave theory
is based on growth so you associate it
usually with fibonacci which i'm gonna
do here
to find some targets so here i can have
one two three four and i'm missing the
fifth wave once again my third wave is
broken down into five waves as well
uh in which the third waves as well
broken down into
five waves so discounting fits very well
for me this is the reason why
i am very confident in a fifth that is
coming
soon the question is when so to to know
that
you come to the fourth wave that is here
and you need to know what kind of
corrective pattern it is so
for example usually when you have here a
zigzag elliot is telling you that when
the second wave is a zigzag the false
wave is usually a flat gaze and this is
true
let's say 70 of the time and
here you can see that i'm having kind of
a flat correction
so this makes total sense for me a b
c and i was telling you guys in my other
videos that i did yes few weeks a few
months ago
that the correction is not done i told
you that you're probably gonna get
rejected and then
i made an update i said tesla will go to
2000 and i still believe this
then we're going to discuss the targets
a bit with more precision
but for sure we are moving higher and to
know
that this scenario is almost 100 sure
we need to have the confirmation that
the corrective phase is
done and here the way i'm gonna find out
that the
the correction is done is when we're
gonna break this trend line guys all
right
so i just connect the two recent highs
that i have
here and here all right like this and
you can see guys that
you know uh so here i told you i made a
video i told you guys buy this dip you
know because i was expecting an abc flat
and not zigzag zigzag would go lower
but i knew it would be a flat most
likely because the second wave was the
zigzag once again so here elliott wave
was very very precious
and here was a very nice level to buy
now i met another update i think around
here and i told you guys now
690 i was talking about this in my
discord
i think i did a video but i'm not sure i
posted it i i don't remember but
whatever
i told you guys in my discord for sure
that 690 is the level to trade above and
you need a confirmation
a daily confirmation yes because we are
here looking at you know a yearly move
so we need a confirmation of the daily
time frame which means two consecutive
candles
on a daily timeframe that close above
the resistance you are considering
which is here a downward sloping trend
line that is right now at 6
17. all right so let's have a look if we
had any confirmation here
i don't see any guys we got we had here
some build up some consolidation
then we got rejected and i told you guys
that i would be a buyer
around the 640 630 area you can go and
check my videos guys or you can check my
discord i told you
this so i gave you this trade guys and i
think it's a very nice tread you can use
fibs to enter
same thing you know fibs guys you can
buy at the 50 and the 61.8 retracement
so here the 50
would be the 6 22 you would have been
executed then the 61.8 percent
retracement you wouldn't
have been done but this you have also
the moving averages here so you know
it's a nice level to buy on a daily
timeframe
so right now if you are not in this
trade you can still expect
here so basically we are moving let me
zoom in a little bit let me
go to the four hours time frame what can
you do if you want to if you are in the
stream
perfect you're good you're good i'm
going to give you some safety
line up some levels below which the
scenario is of the table
but for now let's try how to enter this
trade so as usual we are in the third
wave guys so one
two three fear
bad thing is too late guys maybe you're
gonna have one more re-test one 630 650
is a nice level to buy to be honest
i don't think we're gonna go lower here
uh there are some alternative scenarios
i'm gonna show you that still go lower
but here i think that uh yeah if you are
not in this trade
you can buy a little bit here but i
would in this situation personally
wait for the breakout for the breakout
confirmation and i would buy the retest
all right
buying 650 is a bit too high i would use
fibs once again i measure
the wave that i have here actually you
need to go in the third wave you need to
measure from here to here
okay i would build buy a 620 600 all
right
for sure otherwise i would wait for the
breakout once the breakout is done
in the third wave as usual guys i remind
you that third waves they like
to break some major levels they like to
take back some
levels that are meaningful and that
gives us some information about the
future price action
which here is this 680 670 level right
now it's going
lower so probably the third wave when
it's gonna be complete
is gonna break this level with some
strong moves up and a
strong associated volume very important
guys to check if the
associated volume is big enough to say
that the breakout
is a real breakout and not a fake out so
then here
you're gonna have the force wave usually
coming here
and the fourth wave you know they like
to retrace to the top of the third or
the preceding wave counting so here i'm
not sure about the level yet
but probably it's going to be around the
670 650 area so here you're gonna have
one more opportunity and i think this is
the nice opportunity
to buy if you don't do it we're probably
going to complete this
first wave here around i would say the
780 level something like this and then
we're still going to have a second wave
to correct for example if you want to
buy cold options guys please wait all
right because call options as you know
make you bleed you're gonna pay a lot of
theta every day
and of course if the price action is
going higher you're gonna win
you're gonna make money but if the price
actually comes back and the time has
passed
you are gonna be losing some money that
you would have paid in theta
so if you want to buy call options it's
much better to wait for the last
corrective opportunity for the last
correction
in time that will probably arrive here
around the 15th of september something
like this we're gonna have here probably
a dip
that you guys can use to enter this
trade with like i would say
safety all right this is what i would do
i would buy cool options here
actually you know me maybe here would
have bites bought some shells
definitely not good options but some
shares to build up because you never
know sometimes the retest is going to be
lower you're not going to be able to
enter so maybe buy some shares here
and if you want to buy call options i
would definitely wait here to buy those
call options because the longer you wait
the cheaper you're going to buy those
call options for the same strike
so and in terms of target once again
guys i use
fibs okay
so i measure here
my waves and i applied to the bottom of
the force and the typical retracement
level are
the uh so 61.8 one and one point six one
eight so it gives me one thousand
one thousand four hundred and two
thousand i'm very bullish guys i think
it's going to go to 2000 because i know
that the market
is full of money guys you know because
of the coffee crisis there is so much
cash on hands of many people and money
needs to find a home guys this is the
same we're having when i was working in
banking because i quit my job
as you know and we were saying this
money needs to find a home this is the
reason why the market is so bullish and
i'm very convinced that stocks like
tesla
that have a very bright future they're
gonna probably attract a lot of
money and they're gonna grow more than
the other stocks so
i believe that we might go to 2000 maybe
you know in
two years something like this i don't
really have a time done yet
but i'm very bullish on this stock all
right
who would tv very interesting guys
football tv so here
i'm following the stock for like
something like couple of months guys
i remind you what i was telling you so
here i told you guys careful
this is the only the beginning of the
correction i was here right the
i was a buyer at 22 20 22 on this area
and it broke guys it broke and i told
you guys now the next level is 15. we
went to 15 and we strongly bounced back
then i told you guys just like tesla
that's you know i connected here the
highs that have here
let me go to our little friend to make
this very clean
this is something i did before so it's
anywhere broken
it's not so important but let me do it
well
anyway and here i connected the two
recent highs that i had here and
here guys it's even like this
okay it's not very important here and i
knew that
after this has been broken i made a
video guys and i told you guys guys guys
time to buy
and we had the retest on the trendline
as
uh we often have and i told you guys i
made an update i think here around
the mid-june something like this and i
told you guys careful this is the end of
the first wave
and you can see that on the daily time
frame we had the i i
don't usually use this indicator but i'm
starting to check divergences on the rsi
more and more
and it gives me for example here another
sold signal
so it's not something i use often so i'm
careful with it but it's interesting
that here it gave
me the signal to actually exit i prefer
to use elliot waves and trend lines
to here find the targets and know when
it's time to exit so i told you guys
that the fifth wave is probably going to
measure the same length as the first
wave
and i applied to the bottom of the force
and i gave you i think 35
as a level and then i told you we're
going to correct 227
so right now what happened so this is my
old drawing guys all right so i was not
that wrong on this one let me adjust it
the abc
is like this
okay and we went to
24 now we are trading at 27
so let me check how much retracement is
it compared to the first wave
you see okay so we just touched the 50
retracement so for example if you follow
like just blindly
this method that is basically saying
that you buy the 50 you buy the 61.9
which i like to do guys amongst other
techniques this is one of the techniques
i really like to use you know you don't
need to know a lot about technical
analysis you just
you know once a wave is complete so you
use a trend line to know the weight is
complete
here for example you can see that you
need to find a trainer that had some
support
okay so this one here one two three four
five five reactions on it it broke here
you know this move is complete you
measure the smooth and you buy the
50 and the 61.8 so it's still on the
table that this abc would be longer and
that will go to the 61.8
retracement so which would be 22. so
all this area between 22 and 25
is a nice area for me to buy and then
what is coming guys what is coming the
third wave hopefully so here not sure
the second is finished or not let's put
it here
and then we should have a third wave
that is going to be
the first real move up developing in
five ways in football tv for quite some
time
so let's see how the fundamentals are
going of course this is going to be
related to the fundamentals
technical analysis here is showing us
that there is a lot of
bullish momentum in the stock uh to me
this is looking very
good just in terms of technicals but of
course the fundamentals are important
here as well
i'm not a specialist of this market so i
i don't know exactly how the
fundamentals
but what i'm seeing is that we are set
up for third wave because the first wave
was developing in five waves
so this for me is looking very good then
i expect the third wave maybe to be
rejected at the 65 level which is the
the highest level we had in the past
year and if we break this this is going
to set up the road
for more moves up guys because once
again when you spot a move that is in
five waves
you know that there's going to be more
uh
that this is the direction of the market
all right this is very important to be
able to know if the move you're seeing
is developing in five waves
which means the motif waves are going
higher or if
um the moves up is developing in three
waves abc which means that basically you
are in the corrective
phase so here i had five waves in here
i'm having three ways for nice
for now to correct so this is looking
good for me in terms of targets i don't
really know let's see for now the next
target is 65
and then let's see what is happening
last one guys blackberry
this one is a bit tricky so i checked
here my analysis
i basically i'm bullish yes because on
the long term you can see that we broke
here
so having all this rsi's here you see
it's not so bad this
rsi on um trading view this rsi strategy
is just giving you you know
levels of overbought and oversold level
once again it's not it's not something
that i like to use you know because it's
too basic but it's still good to have it
and you can see that on a stock like
blackberry it's giving you
quite good signals on a daily time frame
so it's something
always interesting to keep in mind so
i'm going to keep them here
and for me the reason i'm bullish is
because we broke this chain line and
you know i like to enlarge the nutrient
lines are giving you the direction of
the market
and when a big trend line like this like
a long-term trend line like this one is
broken
it's very good for the for the longer
term and here you can see we broke it as
usual in the third
of the third wave you can see here doing
my counting
so this is typical guys once again third
waves they like to break some
major level to take back those important
levels and here
we retested it and we had here a strong
support
strong reaction guys which is giving me
more weight to my trend line so i know
that i'm not the one
using it which is making my scenario
even
more likely to be good so here we moved
up and this is for me only the third
and then we corrected sharply guys all
right very sharp
this was the january move that was
driven you know guys by game start amc
mostly gamestop at that time this is the
second move that was more driven by amc
engine so blackberry is just following
you know those two so for now it's just
a bit crushing guys because you know all
the reddit stocks they are losing a bit
momentum but i believe strongly it's
gonna come back
because you know once again the money is
here guys
the confidence is here the bulls uh even
if
it's right now a bit of tough uh time
for the bulls they are still for me in
control for the longer term
what makes me say this guys is because
you can see that
here we're having you know those bullish
divergences you connect here and here
and you can see when i connect here and
here so you connect the recent laws
bam bam on the daily time frame and i
connect the lows
of the rsi yes i can do with the macd or
rsi yes it's the same
sometimes you have it on the macd
sometimes not you know but here i'm
having the rsi
and i'm seeing this uh bullish sheet and
divergence once again let me show you
guys
all right so uh the bullish uh hidden
divergence that i'm having is this one
guys
and as you know i like to use
divergences they are very early signals
and they
remind you what is happening in the
market sometimes you forget you know you
have too many drawings too many lines
you don't even know what is happening
anymore
then you check for divergences and here
this one guys is the
momentum going lower so we are in the
bearish phase we are in correction
but the market is making new lows so the
bears are not able to take more ground
so this is bullish of course and when i
use this divergence so here i'm having
one
uh what is invalidating my signal guys
uh because you always need to have you
know kind of a safety net sometimes you
have a divergence but the market is not
going higher so you need to
find a time when it's time to exit and
for me this is a technique that i use on
my own but that is working well that is
basically
eliminating let's say 30 40 of the
divergences
as you know wrong signals if we break
the trend line that you get by
connecting the two laws of the market
so here it would give me a level around
850.
so below a5850 this divergence on the
long term is invalidating and it might
change my scenario
for now we are still looking good even
if on the short term guys definitely
this is not bullish okay
but amc and gamestop are not bullish as
well i have the feeling all this goes
together
here we broke the 200 moving average on
the first time frame which is not good
but we're having some you can see
oversold signals coming from the rsi all
right
so maybe we're gonna have a reversal
coming soon but here
my scenario would be guys you know that
corrective phase they're moving abc so
maybe an abc like this i don't know
it's hard to say guys it's hard to say
what i would do i would be a buyer
around the 850 area
if i am already in this trade i would
stay in this trade but
below 850 i would maybe you know sold a
bit of my chest
maybe buy lower but once again if you
are in a buy and hold
strategy it's fine just to you know keep
your shares if you don't have leverage
uh you can just accumulate more shares
the lower the price
goes it's a good strategy and strategy
that i think most of people
should use because pro training is
requires a lot of time
a lot of knowledge a lot of nerves you
need to you know stay
in front of your screen for a long time
i know what i'm talking about and it's
not something that everybody
wants to do so here if you just want to
accumulate
to average down your price you can just
buy more shares at the 850
level and then my scenario i think i
need to i'm not sure this is still good
you know this would more look
like this guys all right this correction
is too long so
maybe this would be yeah i did the fifth
wave here so sorry up
abc so either we have in here a one two
three four five
okay it's possible going around the 65
area like i said before the system on
the table
or more likely so this then would be
like this sorry
so let me show you again
okay it would be like this guys but more
likely yes this is not looking like a
one two one two dot you know the two
the second waves are usually sharp
they're not long like this all right so
this doesn't look like a second wave to
me
so i change my analysis here and i
just bring this here bam you know second
wave they're more like this you know
fourth wave they can be longer all right
but
you know they like to take some time for
swags but second left they are usually
sharp
in time and then bam we would be like
this and then this would
maybe only be a wxy correction
all right maybe something like this okay
so let's see guys let's find out below
850
i need to reconsider my analysis because
the bullish divergence is not
active for me anymore the level that
makes me feel very good
is of course about about 16 guys when we
break this you know
here we have this massive selling
pressure that arrived at this level
which is
of course not good guys so we need to
actually
beat the bears that we're sitting here
so to beat them we need to
break this trendline guess so i know
it's a level that is quite far
but this is the level so 60 higher guys
i know but this is the level above which
the scenario is really looking good
for now my scenario would be something
like this so i'm going to keep this
drawing let's find out if this is
correct
but once again we're having the
long-term bullish divergence and we are
trading above this trend line that is
telling me that we are bullish we are a
bullish development
this just might take some more time so
guys that's it for me i hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore
see you guys